Okay.
Things are sort of mixed up this week because
of the 4th of July holiday.
So the Wednesday show is going to be the day
we take live calls instead of the Friday show.
That would cause us to miss out on hatred
mail, which a lot of people don't want to
do a, so we are going to get to hatred mail
a day early today.
Quick Reminder.
What is hatred?
Mail?
This is hatred mail.
Hey, we'd probably poison our entire family
of Trump.
Told us to, but remember, it's not a cold.
Hey, triaged written by patriots who hate
David Pacman because America and because freedom.
Okay.
Uh, this week's hatred mail, picking up on
a theme from Donald Trump's state of the Union
address and that has continued, which is the
theme of this is not going to become a communist
country, which of course is a total straw
man talking point because there's really no
threat of the United States becoming a communist
country.
Take a listen to this.
Pacman is a wishy washy word smithing Jew
using vague terms like progressive's when
it's all if cover for social democracy, socialism,
communism, and are kiss him, et cetera.
Progressive doesn't mean just because of vague
idea of progress is involved.
It communist specific kind as progress.
They see it as conservativism in human clothes.
We will never even be communists mag sa.
Yeah, mags.
A some kind of make America greatly stupid
again, I guess is what Maxa would mean.
A, I'm going to assume that's a typo based
on the proximity of a and s on computer keyboards.
The number one way to fight hatred, autism
and to push back against it is to sign up
for a David Pakman show membership and use
the coupon code hatred 40 the coupon code
hatred 40 saves you 40% off of a membership.
You get all of the same member benefits as
everybody else who paid full price a and hatred.
It's don't like it when their hatred autism
leads to membership.
Patriot 40 is the coupon code.
It'll save you 40% off of the membership of
your choice@wwwdotjoinpacman.com